ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะผู้หญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนผู้ฟ้าคะวัน
นี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วันอังคาร
วันนี้วันอังคารวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 3
วันที่ 3 เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
พฤษภาคม
ปีพตอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
ปีคศอะไรคะปีคศ 2  022 ค่ะค่ะเมื่อวานนี้
วันอะไรคะเมื่อวานนี้วันจันทร์
วันที่ตัวเท่าไหร่คะวันที่
2 เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
พฤษภาคมปีพตต
ปีพต 2  5  6 ห้าปีคศปีคศ 2  022 ค่ะค่ะ
พรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะพรุ่งนี้วันพุธ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 4 ค่ะดีเดือน
พฤษภาคม
ปีพตที่พ.ต.ต.
2565 ปีค.ศต.ค.ปีคศ 2  022 ค่ะค่ะตอนนี้
เวลากี่โมงคะครูฟ้าตอนนี้เวลา
มีวง
7 เลข 4 นะคะ 4 โมงกี่นาทีคะ
40 นาทีค่ะ
40 นาทีก็เป็นเวลากลางวันแล้วแต่ละตอน
เย็นนะคะเย็นแล้ว
แล้วได้ไหมก็คนนักเรียนวันนี้วันนี้วัน
อังคารใช่ไหมวันนี้วันอังคารเทศไทยเนี่ย
หน้าเรานะ
ประเทศไทยหนาวกี่องศาเซลเซียสคะครูหญิง
อุ้ยนี่ของผู้หญิงและ 27 องศาเซลเซียส
นักเรียนเราก็ความรู้สึกก็คือ 30 ใช่มั้ย
มหาวเวลาหนาวเนี่ยถ้าเราผม
อาบผมจะเอาใช่ไหมครูฟ้าผมยาวครูหญิงผมยาว
เนี่ยดีใช่ไหมเวลาอากาศหนาวทำไมเนี่ย
ก็ไปลาผมยาวมีผมเราก็ไม่หนาวไง
แต่ถ้าประเทศไทยร้อน
40 องศาเซลเซียส
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยผมยาวแล้วจะบอก
มันร้อน
ผมยาววุฒิให้หักผู้หญิงถ้าผมยาวแล้วร้อน
โอเคของมันเองครูฟ้าครูฟ้าชอบผมครูฟ้าไหม
คะ
ชอบผมไหม
ไม่ค่ะผู้หญิงเอ้าทำไม
มาไม่ชอบห่มฟ้าครูฟ้าเนี่ยผมตรงแต่
ขอแบบนี้ใช่ไหมอยากได้รูปเนี่ยผู้หญิงคน
นี้เนี่ยผมตรงแบบผมเนี่ยตรง
ตรวจผมตรงครูฟ้าเนี่ยผมตรงรูฟ้าไม่ชอบผม
ตรงหรอครูฟ้าไม่ชอบผมตรงเอางั้นครูฟ้าชอบ
เห็นอยากโศกไหมครูมาชอบผมหยักศกค่ะอ๋อ
ครูหญิงเนี่ยผมอยากสบกลิ่งไม่ชอบทำไม
ผู้หญิงชอบ
ผมตรง
ครูฟ้าผมตรง
ชอบผมอยากสบเดี๋ยวผมจะสอบแล้วก็จะอีกนิด
หน่อยค่ะ
และก็มีอะไรอีกกูฟ้าครูความไม่ชอบแบบนี้
หรอผมหยิกซอยผมหยิกผมหยิบเราก็ดีนะอันนี้
ก็ดีนะคือพรรคก็ชอบผมหญิงน่ะแต่ผมครูฟ้า
เนี่ยเป็นแบบไหนนะคะผมหยิกอ้าวไม่ไปผม
อยากสบหรือว่าผมตรงผมครูฟ้าเป็นผมตรงผม
ตรงสีอะไรคะสีดำสีดำสีดำ
ผู้หญิงเป็นผมแบบไหนคะผมครูหญิงเป็นผม
อยากโศกค่ะ
งูสีอะไรสีดำเหมือนผมครูฟ้าแต่ครูฟ้ากับ
ครูหญิงเนี่ยไม่ได้
หมีพูห์ฟ้ากับผมผู้หญิงเนี่ยไม่ใช่ผมหยิก
ใส่ผมหยิบอันนี้ไม่ใช่นะคะอันนี้ผมของเรา
เนอะผมนักเรียนเป็นยังไงนะคะต่อไป
ฟ้าคิดว่าอิอิ
อย่าหัวเราะเดี๋ยวเรียนไม่รู้เรื่องผู้
หญิงจะถามอะไรเพราะว่าข้อที่แล้วคุณหญิง
ถามเกี่ยวกับผมครูฟ้าไปแล้ว
ลูกค้าคิดว่า
ผู้หญิงจะถาม
หน้าผากกระจายนี่เนาะ
อันนี้นะคะหน้าผากนะอยากในรูปเนี่ยผู้
หญิงคนนี้หน้าผากเขาเป็นยังไงคะหน้าผาก
กว้างค่ะหน้าผากกว้าง
หรือว่าถ้าเราผัดครูเขานะคะเนี่ยหน้าผาก
ว่างไหม
ว่างไหมอ่ะ
กว้างนะ
จะไม่ไม่ไม่ไม่ไม่เท่ากับในรูปสมัยแต่ใคร
เข้าไป
อันนี้ความไปขึ้น
ผู้ชายไงถ้าผู้ชายเนี่ยหน้าผากกว้างขนาด
นี้ได้แต่ครูฟ้าครูฟ้าเป็นคนหน้าผากกว้าง
ไหม
เมื่อก่อนกูฟ้าหน้าผากแคบนะอ๋อนี่ไงถ้า
ครูปลาไม่ใช่นะผักว่างมันก็จะเป็นแบบนี้
อันนี้หน้าผากแคบใช่ไหมคะเห็นไหมหน้าผาก
แล้วก็ที่นี่แคบส่วนอันนี้เนี่ยหู
กวาง
เมื่อก่อนครูฟ้าหน้าผากแคบเหรอคะใช่หา
เมื่อก่อนครูฟ้าหน้าผากแคบคุณแม่และก็
กุมภานะค่ะแคบไม่มีผมหน้าม้าผมหน้าม้าถ้า
ผู้ป้าหน้าผากแคบกว่าต้องไม่มีผมหน้าม้า
น่าจะอร่อยๆได้หาเมื่อก่อนฟ้านะผักแขกนะ
คะ
เพราะว่าเวลาเช็คใหญ่ภูฟ้าเขาก็บอกว่าให้
เราเอานิ้วใช่ไหมคะถ้าอย่างครูหญิงนะหน้า
ผากผู้หญิงนะแค่ 2 นิ้ว 5 แนะหน้าผากแคบ
ดูหน้ากากครูฟ้าสิ
ไฟฟ้ามันเดี๋ยวแม่ของผู้หญิงน่ะได้แค่ 2
นิ้วเลยมีแค่ 2 นิ้วเท่านั้นผู้หญิงเนี่ย
หน้าผากแคบแต่ Cruise
รู้ฟ้ากี่นิ้ว 4 นิ้วเลยเหรอคะ
อันนี้ครูบาเละกับผู้หญิงก๋วยเตี๋ยวนิ้ว
ผู้หญิงก็เล็กอิอิ
แค่ตรงหน้าผากกว้างครูฟ้าอ่ะถ้าเธอครูฟ้า
หน้าผากกว้างเนาะรูหญิงหน้าผากแคบที่จัง
เราสองคนเนี่ยเวลาดูแล้วไม่เหมือนกัน
นะนักเรียนหน้าผากคุณปานะได้ดูนะคะผู้
หญิงสิหนึ่งไหมแล้วผู้หญิงแค่มากเลย
ประมาณ 2 นิ้วหน่อยหน่อยๆ
อันนี้หน้าผากครูฟ้านั้นหน้าผากผู้หญิง
ครูขวาเนี่ยก็เป็นคนหน้าผากกว้างสวยหน้า
ผากกว้าง
ครูหญิงเป็นคนหน้าผากแคบอาหารแขนอ่ะต่อไป
ฝากครูฟ้ากินว่าคุย
3 อะไรรู้ฟ้า
คิดว่าครูหญิงจะถามชิ้วไปค่ะในรูปเนี่ย
หิวเนาะหิวของผู้หญิงเป็นยังไงคะอ๋อไม่
รู้หนา acute นะรูปนี้แหละคิ้วหนาแล้วรูป
นี้แล้วคะ
คิ้วมางนี้คิ้วบางครูฟ้าเนี่ยครูป๊าเป็น
คนคิ้วบางหรือว่าคิ้วหนา
ก้อนหานะสำหรับผู้หญิงเพราะว่ากูฟ้าและมี
มีดนี่เออ
ไอ้ฟ้ากูเชิ้ตมีมีทำอะไร
ไม่ใช่นี่แล้วเย้
เดี๋ยวมาแล้วจะถึง
ครูฟ้าเขากำลังไปหามีดนะคะเพราะว่ากูช้า
ก็บอกว่าเขามีมีดผู้หญิงเนี่ยมีมีด
Capture
มีแต่ก็มีแบบนี้มันไม่ใช่ไงมันไม่ใช่ค่ะ
นั้นพี่อ้ะมันหมดมันไม่ใช่มันไม่ใช่
มีด
น้องมิกซ์โอน
ไม่มีเป็นอย่างนี้มีอะไร
มีดนามีดเอาไว้
กันคิ้ว
หาสมุดว่าถ้าคะอันนี้เป็นมีดใช่ไหมเราก็
groupon เนี่ยก็เอามีดและการเราไม่ได้นะ
คะ
อะไรกันกันกันให้มันคิ้วมันบาง
ๆใช่
การคิ้วนะก็เลย
กูมาก็แช่หนา
ใช่คุยก็ว่าครูฟ้าเป็นคนคิ้วหนาคิ้วหนาก็
คือภูฟ้านะมีขนคิ้วขนคิ้วเนี่ยขนคิ้วเยอะ
ๆก็จะเป็นคนคิ้วหนาผู้หญิงคิ้วหนาหรือ
คิ้วบางกูเองเนี่ยเป็นคนคิ้วบางเอาก็มีนะ
อันนี้อันนี้กูหญิงมามีมาสคาร่าแล้วก็ปัด
คิ้วค่ะถ้าไม่มีแหละคุยก็จะเป็นคนคิ้วบาง
ใช่มั้ยก็จะมีขนคิ้ว
มีขนคิ้วนิดหน่อยครูฟ้าเนี่ยคิ้วหนาก็จะ
มีขนคิ้วขนคิ้วขนคิ้วมากๆ
ใช่ค่ะต่อไปนะคะเราก็ไม่เหมือนกันอีกแล้ว
ครูฟ้าคิ้วหนาหูฟ้า
ครูหญิงหิวบางนะคะอ่ะต่อไปค่ะครูฟ้ากิน
ว่ากูหญิงจะถามอะไร
ว่าคิดว่ากูหญิงจะถามตาค่ะตาใช่ไหมในรูป
นี้เนี่ยผู้หญิงเขาตาเป็นยังไงคะ
ตาโตตาโตตัวที่ตาของเขาหน้าตาโต
แล้วรูปนี้ล่ะคะอ่ะออกมาเล็กตาเล็กเนาะ
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยเป็นคนตาเล็กหรือว่าตาโต
ไม่รู้
รู้ซุ้มรับคนไทยก็โตนะ
ตาใกล้ๆไหมให้มันไม่ได้โปรมากแต่ก็ไม่ใช่
คนตาเล็ก
อ้า
ฉัน you ครูหญิงสิครูหญิงเนี่ยตาเล็กกับ
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยตาโตกว่าครูหญิงมาเรียนดู
อา
ครูหญิงตาเล็กกว่าครูฟ้าครูฟ้าตาโตกว่า
ครูหญิงแต่ถ้านักเรียนเป็นฝรั่งนักเรียน
ตาโตก็จะนักเรียนตาโตมากกว่าครูฟ้ามาก
กว่าผู้หญิงต่อรองก็อาจโอตาเล็กไปค่ะเต๋า
ๆอะไรก็ได้
กินอะไรอ่ะของผู้หญิงมันขึ้นอะไรก็ไม่รู้
ค่ะอ่ะต่อไปค่ะครูฟ้าคิดว่าครูหญิงสถาม
อะไรคะครูฟ้าคิดว่าครูหญิงจะถามจมูกไก่
ค่ะจมูกใช่ไหมตรงนี้เนี่ยเราเรียกว่าสัน
จมูกนะสันจมูกครูฟ้าในรูปเนี่ยจมูกเป็น
ยังไงคะ
จมูกโด่งสมุดโด่งเวลามองข้างๆจะเห็นใช่
ไหมจมูกโด่งแล้ว
รูปนี้ล่ะคะจมูก
เรียกว่าอะไรนะจมูกแบนจมูกแบนอาสมุดแบน
ครูฟ้าคู่ก็มีจมูกใช่ไหมคะ
มีจมูกค่ะความมีจมูกจมูก
สีฟ้าเป็นยังไง
จมูกคู่ฟ้าหรอ
โต้แผ่นนะ
ฮะแบนไหมหรือว่าโด่ง
โอเคนะกูฟ้าคือฟ้าปลายจมูกใช่มั้ยตรงนี้
เนี่ยปลายจมูกของครูฟ้าเนี่ย
ปลายจมูกครูฟ้าเนี่ยแหลมลายจมูกภูฟ้าแหลม
แก้มบัง
ครูฟ้ากับครูหญิงแล้วก็นักเรียนสมัยนัก
เรียนที่เป็นฝรั่งเป็นคนยุโรปคนอเมริกา
นักเรียนก็จะจมูกโด่งและมากกว่าครูหญิง
กับครูป๊าในหากวิ่งกับผู้ค้าก็จมูกแบนนะ
จมูกแบนมากกว่านักเรียน
หรือว่าจมูกเอาจมูกแบนมากกว่านักเรียน
จมูกโด่งน้อยกว่านักเรียนคือผู้หญิงกับ
ครูป๊าครูฟ้าอยากจมูกโด่งไหม
ยากค่ะผู้หญิง
ต้องไปคลินิกค่ะซิลิโคน
ไปใส่ซิลิโคนนะคะลายค่ะอีกคันนึงรูฟ้าคิด
ว่าข้อนี้เนี่ยครูหญิงจะถามเกี่ยวกับอะไร
ปาก
ปากใช่ไหมคะในรูปนี้เนี่ยเขาผู้หญิงคนนี้
ป่าเขาเป็นยังไงคะ
ปากแดง
อ่อนแดงใช่เขาทาลิปสติกสีแดง
ปากหมา
ยังไงปากหนาเห็นไหมเพราะว่ามันจะมีริมฝี
ปากบนริมฝีปากล่างหนาหวานน่ารักปากเนื้อ
หา
แค่รูปนี้ล่ะคะป่าเป็นยังไงปากบางใส่ปาก
บางชนิดริมฝีปากบนดินฝีปากล่างเนี่ยบางๆ
นะคะหาลิปสติกนิดหน่อยอ่ะ
แล้วสรุปนี้ล่ะแบบเป็นยังไงปากใหญ่ปาก
ใหญ่หรือว่าปากอะไรอ่ะปากยิ้ม
ว่างขอ
กวางปากว่าไงเวลายิ้มเนี่ย
น้าผู้หญิงกับครูฟ้าเนี่ยปากกว้างไหมกู
ฟ้าได้อยู่แล้วเหมือนคู่ค้าเลยรูปนี้
naoka ไหมปากกว้างโอเคค่ะ
ใช่ไหมโอเคน้องมีจะมี superstar หนึ่งคน
น่ะ
กว้างมากที่ไม่ใช่จูเรียโรเบิดนะ
ใครคะ
ที่นี่หรอคนนี้นะอันนี้ก็ปากกว้างไหม
อานะกวางป่ากว้างนะคะคือเราสองคนและก็ปาก
กว้างนะคะแต่ว่าแล้วปากของเราล่ะครูหยี
กับครูฟ้าเนี่ยปากครูฟ้าเนี่ยบางหรือว่า
หนา
ไม่บางแต่ก็ไม่ไปก็นะ
จะไม่มาก
อ้าก็นะกูฟ้าผู้หญิงผู้หญิงก็ถ้ากูฟ้า
อยู่ไกลๆครูหญิงก็เห็นปากครูฟ้านะก็ต้อง
เห็นติดผู้หญิงไม่เห็นก็รู้ป่าวไม่มีปาก
นะ
อยู่บ้านน้าน้องคนคนไทยน้องคนไทยหลายๆคน
ก็จะปากหนาสมัครจะเห็นริมฝีปากริมฝีปาก
ชัดๆทหารอันนี้ก็คือครูฟ้าใช่ไหมโทรฟ้า
เนี่ย
อยู่ไหนนะคะไปให้หมดเนาะครูฟ้ามาหาครูฟ้า
เนี่ยก็ครูฟ้าก็จะเป็นคนที่ผมตรง
ตรงมาหน้าผากกว้างนะคะแต่ว่ามีผมมา
คิ้วหนา
หิวหนา
ก็เป็นยังไงอีกเหรอ
ตาตกการ์ตูน
การ์ตูนกว่าผู้หญิงไงตาโตตาล่ะ
ชั่วโมงเนี่ยลายสมุกแหลมเราก็จะอ้าปากหา
นะ
อันนี้ครูฟ้านะคะวันนี้ต่อไปครูหญิง
ผู้หญิงเป็นยังไงผู้หญิงนะคะกูหญิงก็จะ
เป็นคนผมอยากสบนะผมอยากโสบหน้าผากแคบนะคะ
หน้าผากแคบ
แล้วก็
คิ้ว
ผิวบางไม่แค่พอนะคะคิ้วบางคิ้วปางหิวบ่าง
ได้
ปลาเล็กหาเล็กหน้าตาเล็กมองไม่เห็นตาเลย
นะคะนักเรียน
ตาแลก
รองหูแบน
ปากบางแต่บางบ้านสาอันนี้ครูหญิงนะคะๆตัว
อะไร
นักเรียนอ่ะแล้วนักเรียนเหรอคะนักเรียนผม
หยักศกไหมคิ้วหนาหรือบางตาโตตาเล็กจมูก
โด่งจมูกแบนปากหนาปากเล็กปากกว้างปากบาร์
รถใจเย็นๆนักเรียนแม่เรียนคิดว่าคนนี้
เนี่ยเหมือนครูฟ้าไหมแล้วก็คนนี้มึง
เหมือนครูหญิงไหม
อันนี้ก็คือเวลานักเรียนมองเรานะคะก็จะ
เห็นอันนี้ครูฟ้าผมตรงอยู่หน้าตาโตจมูก
โด่งปากหนาก็คือหญิงผมอย่าศพคิ้วบางตา
เล็กหน้าผากแคบจมูกแบนอ้าปากหนาก็จะเป็น
ของเราสองคนเนาะไม่รู้ว่านักเรียนเป็นยัง
ไงนะคะคอมเม้นท์บอกเราได้ตัวนี้กูเองกับ
ผู้ฟ้าก็ต้องไปก่อนแล้วเจอกันวีดีโอหน้า
สวัสดีค่ะอ่า
[เพลง]